at exactly 6 a.m on january 18 2014 the
sun began peeking above the horizon in
luanda angola marking the beginning of
what seemed at the time like any
ordinary day
just seven nautical miles off the coast
sat anchored kerala a greek owned
liberian flagged and golden chartered
oil tanker
corolla had just loaded 60 000 metric
tons of diesel and was carrying a
27-person crew when something strange
happened
the ship suddenly stopped broadcasting a
signal
its owner tried but failed to make
contact
as far as any map satellite or radar was
concerned kerala stopped existing
an entire day went by
nothing
then another day and another then five
more
finally on sunday january 26th eight
days after its disappearance the tanker
emerged 1300 miles north off the coast
of nigeria
it wasn't hard to put the pieces
together
thirteen thousand tons of oil worth 8
million dollars was missing one crew
member injured and the ship's
identification markers painted over
in case there remained any doubt that
this was a clear case of piracy a
suspicious tugboat had been sighted
nearby
instead the plot thickened
sponsored by morningbrew the free daily
newsletter that keeps you up to date on
the world of tech and business
when you hear the word piracy you
probably think consciously or otherwise
of somalia
for a long time this was the capital of
maritime hijackings
at its peak in 2011
736 crew members and 32 ships were held
hostage
why somalia
the answer seems obvious
the average person lives just 57 years
and its gdp per capita is the second
lowest of any country on earth
it ranks at the bottom in fact of nearly
every metric where data is available
but while most of the population lives
on less than one us dollar a day just a
few miles off the coast pass by ships
carrying many millions of dollars in
cargo
to put things in perspective somali
pirates collected an estimated 70
million dollars in 2009 which would make
it the country's third most lucrative
industry after gold and sheep and goats
the actual cost of piracy on the other
hand is much larger it includes not only
the ransoms themselves but also the
second order costs of prevention
insurance and lost
efficiencies when everything from hired
security to longer alternate routes are
factored in a single hijacking between
europe and asia increases the overall
maritime shipping cost that year by 1.2
percent
now around 2009 the world collectively
decided enough was enough
nato's operation ocean shield was led by
the us but everyone from norway to
pakistan china and even russia pitched
in
it's a strange set of circumstances that
gets india and pakistan the us and
russia and china and japan to fight on
the same side but nobody likes pirates
and to the surprise of no one guided
missile destroyers and their assortment
of seahawk helicopters were victorious
over a few dozen wooden skiffs
since 2018 thanks to an aggressive
military response both mercenary and
naval no attacks have occurred in the
international waters around somalia
piracy it seemed was becoming a thing of
the past
then like a game of whack-a-mole it
sprung up somewhere else
this time on the other side of africa
around the gulf of guinea whose
coastline stretches nearly 4 000 miles
from senegal to angola
today a staggering 95 percent of all
global kidnappings occur in these waters
eight of the nine ships fired upon in
2015 were traveling through the gulf of
guinea
in 2017 over a third of all ships
passing through the region carried
kidnapping and ransom insurance
although it hasn't yet reached the level
of somalia at its peak the niger delta
is becoming the new global piracy
hotspot
half of nigeria lives in what the u.n
calls multi-dimensional poverty which
measures both income and other factors
like health care and education
wherever there's poverty plus
opportunity it seems piracy will follow
yesterday somalia today nigeria and
tomorrow somewhere else
or so it appears on the surface
in reality what we've come to think of
as piracy is more a result of specific
circumstances within somalia than the
explanations hollywood popularized
piracy in each region is based on
entirely different culturally and
economically distinct business models
the central problem facing the country
of somalia is that it's hardly a country
at all
since the collapse of a centralized
government in 1991 somalia has been
ruled by regional fiefdoms with varying
degrees of law and order
over the course of one 16-year period no
fewer than 14 failed attempts were made
to establish a new national government
the result is that while most of the
world recognizes only one sovereign
somali state there are in effect several
self-proclaimed independent governments
and warlords
one of which somaliland acts in practice
like any other nation issuing its own
passports holding its own elections and
enforcing its own customs
this inability by the central government
to project power beyond the capital
combined with droughts and aggravated by
insurgents means that a general
lawlessness pervades the region
the resulting unemployment is one of the
primary drivers of piracy yet somalis
have simultaneously turned this into a
strategic advantage
anyone anywhere in the world armed with
an ak-47 and some bravery can attack a
ship most of which really only travel at
20 or 25 miles an hour
the problem is what you do after that
the most valuable cargo on a ship is its
crew from which you can potentially
extract anywhere from 700 000 to nearly
10 million dollars in ransoms
but kidnappings are no walk in the park
fresh-faced pirates are promised action
and adventure but soon discover they're
more like small business owners
just as new franchisees realize all
they've done is paid for the right to
flip burgers being a pirate isn't all
it's cracked up to be
most of the job is spent transporting
guarding and feeding hostages doing
bookkeeping and above all patiently
waiting
for every one person holding a gun
announcing i'm the captain now there's
at least one more doing the boring grunt
work on shore
during the heyday many coastal
communities were based entirely around
supporting this industry
the average length of a kidnap for
ransom operation is six months and some
negotiations drag on for over a year
that's six whole months of just waiting
trying not to get caught
but herein lies somalia's advantage
its complete and utter lack of formal
institutions a motivated police force or
functioning government means that its
pirates can afford to hold hostages as
long as necessary without fear of being
found out
[Music]
then there's west africa
the region's economic center is nigeria
by far the most populous country on the
continent
nigeria is an oil giant its over 600
fields pump out 2 million barrels of
crude oil a day
the industry generates 95 of the
country's foreign exchange and 80
percent of its budgetary revenues
yet in a classic case of the resource
curse only about a quarter of its oil is
refined domestically
the rest is shipped abroad refined and
returned in an expensive and inefficient
cycle
to avert protest against a system that
clearly benefits only far away
corporations and corrupt local
politicians oil imports are heavily
subsidized making its fuel among the
cheapest in the world corruption
resource dependency and exploitation
mean that despite producing more oil
than anywhere else in africa nigerians
lack reliable access to electricity
instead spending 9 million a year on
fuel for generators
on top of all this oil importers
regularly decide they aren't getting
properly compensated cut off supply and
create shortages around the country
the result is unmet demand for fuel and
a pervasive sense of injustice
it's hard to feel constrained by the law
when it's abundantly clear that no one
from local administrators to top
officials do either
one way this manifests is illegal
makeshift oil refineries
a group of entrepreneurs will set up
camp in the swamp burn crude oil and
open air pits and sell whatever comes
out the other end at gas stations across
the country
the other way is known as petropiracy an
extension of the widespread plunder of
oil that occurs in rivers and pipelines
across the niger delta
unlike in somalia where most pirate
attacks are kidnappings a significant
number here are oil seizures targeting
tankers
in 2016 pirates stole 400 000 barrels of
crude oil every single day in the gulf
of guinea for a total loss of 750
million dollars in 2019 alone
ironically part of nigeria's problem is
the opposite of somalias
where somali piracy flourished in the
absence of a state piracy in the gulf of
guinea is often enabled by it
put another way its problem is that it
has too strong a formal economy and not
enough lawlessness
recall the case of kerala
logistically it would have been
difficult to hide a ship of that size
for months at a time as was often done
around somalia
on the other hand some semblance of
formal institutions and markets are an
asset for nigerian pirates there's
always an unscrupulous buyer for stolen
oil
petro-piracy is sophisticated
for starters it happens really fast
sometimes oil is seized and resold in a
matter of hours quickly and untraceably
moving between the 20 countries in the
gulf of guinea
attacks often require insider
information connections and planning
some studies suggest there's a kind of
sweet spot between anarchy and order
that maximizes opportunity for piracy
after a ransom was successfully paid for
mv victoria a freighter attacked around
somalia in 2009 for instance pirates
offered to stay on board until it
reached safety to ensure it wasn't
hijacked by a competing gang
similarly when al qaeda tried to set up
shop in somalia during the 90s it was
frustrated by its lack of policing
self-protection is costly and
time-consuming even for pirates and
terrorists
when kerala was eventually found the
angolan navy conducted an investigation
its verdict the whole episode was faked
there was no hijacking and the
suspicious tug was instead a replica
what this means is either that someone
on the ship itself coordinated the
attack
or the angolan government dismissed
evidence of what would be the most
southern attack in the gulf of guinea at
the time worrying that it would deter
shippers and harm the economy
as you can see the lines between the
formal and informal economies and the
good and bad guys are blurred and
sometimes even change from one day to
the next
the lesson if there is one is that
stamping out piracy once and for all is
nearly
impossible take the case of somalia
while it's true that the robust
multilateral naval response was indeed
effective it wasn't quite as successful
as it may seem
rather than disappearing overnight
pirates and nearby ships especially
fishing vessels reached a sort of mutual
agreement
pay us for a fishing license and you
won't be disturbed
nigerians likewise conveniently though
at times convincingly argue that oil
companies who profit from but give very
little back to the country aren't the
real pirates extracting value from the
land for the benefit of few
as long as these fundamental
inequalities remain piracy will only
adapt in its outward appearance moving
on land and changing in name
one thing that hasn't changed much is
how we get our news i can spend hours
scrolling through reddit and twitter and
not really remember anything today's
sponsor morningbrew is a better way to
stay up to date on the world of tech
business and finance
what i like about morningbrew is that
it's self-contained there's a start and
an end not an infinite scroll
every issue was interesting witty and
condensed so you can feel accomplished
up to date and learn something new in
the first 10 minutes of your day
in a recent morning brew for example i
learned that amazon today has doubled
the number of employees it did at the
start of 2020.
amazingly it also makes more revenue
from advertising than youtube
click the link on screen or in the
description now to sign up for the
morning brew newsletter 100 completely
free and in just 15 seconds sign up give
it a try and thanks again to morningbrew
for sponsoring this video